here lies a sleeping giant let her sleep
for when she awakes the world will
tremble a giant that Napoleon once
prophetically spoke about is the world's
oldest continuous civilization and the
most populous nation on earth that has
the largest number of Internet users in
the world a large number of cities over
a million people the largest luxury
market in the world as well as the
world's most ferocious consumer of
energy this giant is China
as someone who was made in China
designed in New Zealand and now exported
out to the US I've always thought about
perceptions of China both within and
without what kind of words come to mind
when I mentioned China admiration in the
fear the common thread seems to be one
in the lack of understanding and
opaqueness my hope in my talk today is
that you will take away some new
understanding in the way that China
thinks and operates and that you'll gain
a new appreciation and genuine sense of
empathy for a nation that we just can't
ignore and a nation that one sick of
humanity calls home 16 of humanity yeah
you've heard this before China has like
a gazillion people aka the world's
factory and why not china after all is
all about math all about Mac you thought
that was done and finished in elementary
school yes China is all about math
when you multiply anything by 1.4
billion it becomes a rather large number
but the outside world often forgets that
math works those ways just as there is
multiplication there is also division
and when anything is divided by 1.4
billion everything suddenly seems so
small that attractive luxury market most
of the users most of the consumers are
less than 2,000 u.s. dollars a year the
ferocious consumer of energy on a per
capita basis is a mere 17 that of the US
and that gigantic Internet user base
well eighty percent of them don't even
hold college degrees I still remember
the very first time I visited my
relatives in Beijing like any eager
twelve-year-old boy I wanted to check
out the theme parks pearman square
Forbidden City after a rather long
12-hour flight from New Zealand sorry
Bowen we can't really go today because
it's a old number day we can only go on
even-numbered days my uncle said
matter-of-factly what is he all about
just didn't add up my uncle had a car
the roads led from his house to the park
we drive there have fun case closed
what's this odd and even thing seeing
that I was utterly confused my uncle
then patiently explained why l've on
Beijing has too many cars
and as a result of that we've been
breathing some pretty bad here so the
government put in this new policy where
all numbered license plates cars with
odd number license plates can only be
driven on certain days and even on the
other that way reduces number of cars in
the world and hints that our ear what
isn't this like a gross encroachment of
my rights as I'd think as a Kiwi or an
American stop do the math
in 2011 alone there were thirteen point
six million noon cars sold in China that
represents a thirty-three percent
year-on-year growth year-on-year growth
is it the right of individual citizens
to buy what they want whenever they want
yeah that's the tenants of free market
is it also the responsibility of
individuals to protect the environment
that seems here then is it right to
limit the use of cars in order to ensure
more sustainable growth hmm that's a
tricky one maybe
you see in order to understand how China
operates we need to understand how the
rulers of China the problems that we
have to face from day to day and the
problems of multiplication and division
that multiplication the cumulative
effect of small individual issues
suddenly becomes very large ones and
division where scarcity is a daily
routine
Thomas Jefferson once hand in the
immortal declaration that all men are
created equal at the endowed by their
creator with certain unalienable rights
that among them are life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness this rather sacred
text is well known by Americans and no
Americans like but what if what if all
three of these elements don't all add up
all at the same time at some stage in a
nation's development and that is the
reality that China faces today and it is
this exact balancing and trade-offs that
is so hard for us who grew up in the
West to fully comprehend you know many
of us at the GSB learn in the first
quarter that different countries are
different but the u.s. really never had
to deal with a country that was so
different and where there is so much
interdependence case in point China
holds nine hundred billion dollars of US
Treasury bills second only to American
taxpayers putting that in perspective
that's one fifth of the US government
bit being while US consumers purchased
425 million billion dollars of Chinese
goods in 2012 alone
that's more than the market
capitalization of a twink once the Most
Valuable American company it is
imperative for the future of the world
for us to genuinely engage and emphasize
and actively seek help understanding
with China and once in a while do the
math and ask ourselves if you were the
rulers of China if you were the ruler of
a country of 1.4 billion people 56
ethnicities 5,000 years of history what
would you do because we are so different
this is hard but it is worth doing
because they're there is no other
country on earth other than the u.s.
they can better influence how the giant
that is China will wake and how the
world will tremble and it's waking thank
you
you